what's up everyone i'm joshua weissman
and these are my favorite snacks
[Music]
that was not my best catch so these are
kettle cooked potato chips salt and
pepper it's old faithful
oh the bags are always bad i go for
kettle cook for two reasons a the crunch
is always better i don't really like
lay's potato chips that much that
immediately dissolves on your tongue
this has texture this is like an
explosion in your mouth they're good no
matter how you serve them by themselves
with a burger doesn't matter they're
just good
oh yeah
wow
i bet a lot of people didn't expect this
from me i already know the comments are
going to be judging me right now josh
you consider yourself a professional and
you're going to eat cheetos get out of
here i don't think i can respect you
anymore you need to be real with
yourself sometimes okay
these are my mom's favorite snack how
could i not like these and include this
on this list
the actual flavor of a cheeto is so nice
and guess what it has msg in it you all
know how i feel about msg it's one of
the greatest seasonings of all time the
cheese flavor profile although it
doesn't taste real it's just good i
don't know why it just is and it's
probably because of the msg isn't it it
has like a deep crunch and then it
dissolves it doesn't just fall apart in
your mouth it has texture so all in all
good snack is it my favorite of all time
no but my mom loves them and so it has a
place in my heart
so next up we have thai tea boba does
this count as a snack i don't know
but
yeah it does actually because you get to
chew on it first off that's the best
part right there
the stab i include this as a favorite
snack because it is good any time of the
day lunchtime after lunch after dinner
you know you're sitting you're watching
a movie you're like i don't really want
popcorn i don't really want a bunch of
sugary snacks but you know what i do
want
this incredibly odd creation that is
somehow so so good you have a textural
wonderland of chew below in the form of
balls
so that's always great the thing that i
love the most is the juxtaposition of
like that chew that starch mixed with
the creaminess of the milk tea so pick
your own tea but this is my personal
choice my personal favorite
oh yeah
here we go now we're in the candy land
let's talk about peanut m ms this is
clearly the superior m m can we not
agree with that a traditional m m is
good and all after five m m's you're
like i'm done this is just like for
children i don't want this like
grotesquely sweet milk chocolate but you
know what helps break that up a nice
salty peanut right in the middle all of
a sudden it's perfectly balanced
like everything should be i feel like
thanos right now but with peanut m
ms nothing but crunch they are way too
addictive they are way too good one of
my favorite candies of all time i know
i'm gonna get roasted for it but that is
what it is
this is another childhood favorite i'm
not even sure if anyone even knows what
these are these have to be the thing
that just line the shelves that everyone
walks past this is a chocolate hazelnut
pirouette and i used to love them as a
kid although i haven't had one in
probably about five years so we're gonna
find out right now whether or not i even
like it
maybe my palette is enhanced
oh they packed these differently
it is a wafer that is stuffed with
chocolate hazelnut paste
pretty basic
these are a perfectly binchable food it
somehow
tastes good and tastes better the more
that you eat it and it doesn't take up
any space in your stomach
oh
not everybody knows what these are
norimaki little nori candies they're
slightly savory slightly sweet this is a
more recent discovery for me
and now i have 15 bags of them in my
pantry and they stay stocked
i stay strapped if you will
this is another perfectly bingeable
snack i'd rather have this over a bowl
of popcorn when watching a movie that's
how good they are it's like a little
firecracker of umami in your mouth if
you're a sushi person and you've never
had this before you might just be
missing out on one of the greatest
snacks of your entire life
oh
this is a finale
yes
these
i feel bad cause i i have the most
energy for this but i love takis my
mouth is already watering so much
ataki is basically just a tortilla chip
and they're wrapped
like this
it's like a little joint of flavor it's
kid friendly don't tell them it looks
like a joint don't give it to your kid
be like this looks like a toy as soon as
i eat this my mouth is gonna be an ocean
so here we go
god they're so good this is a perfect
snack the crunch is always good i never
run across a sogitaki
sagitaki it is
spicy salty acidic it's got the umami it
has everything one could argue that this
is just as good as a perfectly balanced
bowl of tomka guy and the reason why i
bring up tom kagai is because it's a
soup that's supposed to be highly
balanced it's sweet it's salty it's
spicy and well sour at the same time it
has all those elements that is the taki
i'm telling you a chef had to have made
this a culinarian had to have made this
that's too perfect
[Music]
okay so thank you guys for watching
hopefully this uh list of snacks was to
your liking don't forget to get my book
if you haven't alright i just released a
cookbook it's nine times the new york
times bestseller right i'm flexing it
i'm flexing it we worked hard on it it
took a lot of people to make it so be
sure to go check it out but nonetheless
enjoy your day and go get a good god
dang snack okay
[Music]